i think i think that's everything
i think that's everything
guys um are we are we live are we
are we doing this now
is this the real deal yes is
all right hey um
wow okay so here we are we are one
minute prior to the go live of son of a
dungeon here on the corridor podcast uh
we thought it would be fun to do
a
just bit of a director's commentary as
we watch through this with everybody
both on the website corridor digital.com
and on youtube uh the first episode is
premiering on youtube and going live on
the website in about 30 seconds and so
we're gonna look at comments we're gonna
be flipping back and forth from uh
corridor digital.com to uh the youtube
video page and um
we're just gonna be talking about it
reacting to comments and
just um taking part in the experience
really
heck yeah
yeah i got all the chat rooms up on my
mobile devices
so many chat rooms
all
two right
i'm i'm seeing two o'clock
we got two point two thousand people on
youtube tuned in right now that's
amazing
oh it's going it's going here goes oh
it's going on the website
all right scott's adjusting it there we
go there we go perfect
oh sam's little intro it's playing
what's happening
what's going on youtube oh youtube's
getting us there
yeah youtube does that
uh oh
oh okay
my wireless headphones keep
disconnecting
i'll just keep hopslocked to being the
one earpiece
oh man this is intense like
you're just in your silences
i gotta turn the volume down because i'm
like watching the show now
sounds like already watching
season i'm gonna give you a critique
uh jake the ios app i can't see the live
so i have to go to corridor digital.com
listen carmichael's stopped
we're a lot of podcasts
we're working on it
oh yeah i'm actually still trying to
navigate to where the live st the live
stream the website
it's not on youtube yet it is it's
counting
no no it's got a minute remaining on
youtube countdown
hey does someone have no youtube's
telling me 43 seconds yeah yeah yeah
yeah countdown
after the premiere time it's another two
minute two minute timer oh is it okay
hey real talk how do i get to the the
site the website youtube everything has
a website for people to come in
hey i'm gonna ask you again hey how do i
get to the website link
live sam
quarterdigital.com quarterdigital.com
live
thank you
wait what i'm not logged in still crap
dude look at it we're getting all the
comments on our website are two minutes
ahead of youtube right now
everyone's like ooh this looks so sick
you gotta log in dog
david just letting you know that you
killed it
sam killed this that's what he said
this is amazing oh it's starting on
youtube it's starting 2.6
3000 on youtube
i learned a lot from this channel music
is pretty fire
it's looking good
i can't wait until uh yeah youtube is
literally just scrolling
it keeps doing slow mode on the chat for
like a second
yeah
not the best place for
hey sam you should turn off your video
yeah yeah now i can hear you without you
being a robot
um you got it so there's like a bunch of
coordination that went into this launch
with like need to make sure that these
hour-long exports are flawless
oh my gosh yesterday carmichael
goodness you know at the the top of the
day not not even yesterday uh monday top
of the day we have a meeting about how
we're gonna launch
uh these files how we're gonna go about
it i get i get the specific verbal
direction from nico
that if i see a problem i need to fix it
before they get to see it
yes well this was two days ago this was
two days ago and i i was like okay i see
some footage that i would actually
genuinely want to denoise
yeah well don't de-noise last minute
because you're going to get 24-hour
renders
oh god that versus just turning out
surrenders
4k footage man
on 4k hour-long footage yeah that was
i i unders i see what you're
saying but to be honest when i saw that
footage i'm not even going to say what
footage it is it did not i did not
notice i did not notice i was not like
oh this looks grainier than the other
stuff we should denoise this okay
to my eye though it kept on bugging me
and i was like well no one's saying it
through this entire process maybe not
but then the moment nico said that it
got into my head and i was like god damn
it i'm [ __ ] that's because that's
because you're you you know you you and
sam are the guys who see every flaw
yeah
you know so
i had to turn the audio off because i
just started watching it
[Laughter]
i know right you got to do that it's too
intense
yeah
four and a half thousand people are
watching the premiere on youtube damn
so it's crazy that's
so the website version is ahead of the
youtube version right yeah like a couple
minutes yeah okay yeah i know there was
a whole website at the beginning of the
youtube version hey sam how's your hot
air balloon ride going yeah are you in a
hot air ball right now oh yeah
i'm not in a hot air balloon i'm not i
you know what after all those horror
stories i decided against it
oh i'm
when a bunch of peasants beat beat a man
after he landed in a hot air balloon in
their village in the late 1800s
[Laughter]
not made for all
if you watch to the very end of the last
podcast hey uh joey d
conning not made for ultra wide you know
what
16 by nine works
[Laughter]
16x9 is still king at the moment
yeah i'm i mean yeah here we go i'm i'm
i'm deeply looking at that two by one
uh right now as like a future platform
is two by one
okay so which are we going off the
website or the youtube version as far as
like talking i'm gonna be on youtube
because on ios i can't actually see it
on the website either you don't want
either you want
i'm screenshotting everything
no i'm just screencapping back and forth
between chord or digital and
and the youtube video page but i'm
primarily
staying on cd.com uh bowden on youtube
wait that's not mercer
did somebody say that yeah when does ren
break his arm
why does jake have a guitar oh you'll
find out
wren breaks his arm before we film the
live stream he is so hot that that was
the big problem
yeah
ren ren does not have a broken arm in
the game table footage no no then
broken arm is behind the shield that's
why he has the shield yeah
how long did it take to create this show
to quit one year it took a year it
technically took a year
um in the sense that like we we filmed
it in like february march slash april
but yeah uh like planning it out and
conceptualizing and starting to do r d
started
before with that you know i remember it
was september of 2020 when i realized we
could photo scan stuff
so it's a good context a year ago
yeah
yeah that's uh
i mean this technology is moving along
fast too
there's a comment uh that says jake's
thought this was a poker game
it is a d is a poker game yeah you're
gambling story
they haven't realized that yet
everyone's asking where's mercer
man i'm so amped that people are so
amped for this five yeah people are
five plus thousand people on youtube
yeah
yeah it's really cool reading all these
people are like this looks amazing this
looks so nice i love sam's facial
expressions
[Laughter]
the moment it happened at the table the
first thought was like
ah i guess we're going to edit around
that but then the and then after
we finish recording the episode sam and
i get together like we're keeping this
because it's too funny yeah
so a couple of the comments on our on
the crew channel on youtube but i get it
you know i put a lot of stuff on her
channel are just like wait they're just
playing dungeons and dragons
[Laughter]
wait in the in the chat right now yeah
very few very very few very few if i
like one of those this is just y'all
playing d indeed
i mean there's like five million
subscribers or whatever yeah this is
just us playing d that's it uh bo druid
nick that's great that means we made it
look easy the time
d aka reddit the character
dang already loving this
did sam write this campaign himself how
much world building goes into it and how
much is made up on the flies that's a
good question yeah i mentioned uh well
basically like i come up with like a
bunch of broad strokes
and ideas
and then i would like nervously turn the
carmichael and go like all right here's
some ideas and he's like hey that's cool
this is cool that's not cool and then i
kind of take the feedback
jumble it up a bunch and we do that back
and forth a couple of times
and then basically
you know the best way to put it is
it's like a writer's room where it's
like i'm the sh i'm like i'm the writing
showrunner and then nico and jake and
dee and ren are the other writers on the
project and so i'm like here's the story
what do you think should happen next and
then they're like
this and then we go all right and then
that becomes canon and then i compare
that to the notes and we move forward
pretty much
yeah i'm gonna have to turn off auto
scroll on the uh
chat
i can't read them all
i'm a bit disappointed so far well i'm
sorry shape
carmichael give your attention to the
positive comments don't call it the one
in a thousand ladies
first thing that i saw and i was like
wait what
that's because you're reading the
youtube comments
the youtubes
is this really live no
you got yeah six thousand people on
youtube
everyone loves bob with a w 16 i don't
know what that means
well bob
mark campbell told me to be humble and
stop calling stuff the best
look guys we gotta play the game right
hate the hate the game not the player
yeah
people are a few people are competing
with like should it be w bob or bob with
oh bub
yeah i'm surprised it wasn't spelled
b-o-w-b
that's what i thought but then
uh
uh i asked wren how did he initially
want to be spelled and he said w first
i was like all right i'm gonna go with
that
the dice are kind today said one guy in
the comments
this is so much like d it really is
yeah i just saw that one
yo the spam around the comments
oh
all right carmichael
you have to focus on the positive
comments it's just what fills my screen
no seriously you cannot focus on the
native comments anymore i know i'm
trying not to being negative
[Laughter]
all right
everyone's like i can't see it on the
corridor app on youtube
they're looking for video on demand it's
only live right now oh somebody called
out i didn't know these characters named
after two warhammer guys oh
that's a good one
i didn't even know that he probably
doesn't even know that either he's just
like these are cool
cool names
yeah
eight more episodes of this guys eight
more
your throat that's that's the climactic
opening of this show i have a log i'm
going to throw it in the air
[Laughter]
i put a user in
someone said it's a great decision to
mix the comp shots with the full cg
miniature shots
and i totally agree because
we filmed as much as we possibly could
like we filmed like what like
at least 30 and then comes out to like
somewhere between 30 and 40 shots of a
green screen per episode
but that's very affordable when you drop
it into like an hour and so by like
taking the full cg shots and then like
putting the same color grade on it and
like putting the map bars on them you
like create these like little sequences
so you like hold on to that cinematic
vibe like a little bit longer and it's
like way less jarring
it really ended up working out
okay guys i've been out and about doing
the research i've listened to you i've
heard your comments and i've got my
binoculars because i've been looking far
and wide for where you can get the best
stock assets in all of the internet and
i gotta say courtesy of today's sponsor
storyblocks i think i've finally done it
because it's the one stop shop for all
of your stock asset needs now they have
a virtually unlimited library of high
quality 4k video audio images after
effects templates and more and you can
get it all through their cost-effective
subscription plans hey look at that that
is that an unlimited all-access plan
that's going to allow you to download as
much as you want from the site
whenever you want and use it in
any kind of content that you want my
goodness it's all royalty free you can
use it in commercial projects or in
personal projects or in movies or
whatever you want oh my goodness and
what's that over there
no way
that's an enterprise plan if you're part
of a creative team and you guys aren't
using storybox talk to your team leader
about getting an enterprise plan from
storyblocks i can't tell you how many
times that corridor the first thing that
we do is go on to story blocks and see
if they have stock assets that help us
tell the story that we're already
imagining in our heads it's amazing if
you're interested head on over to
storyblocks.comcast and you can get
signed up or click the link in the
description below that's
storyblocks.comcast and man hey
maybe that's you i see out there
it is you
you're clicking the link in the
description below no wait you're signing
up look at you
look at that oh man i can see it now
the future really is brighter
so ren gets the first roll of the game i
didn't realize that
and it's the first time i'm so easy i'm
just throwing it in the first moment
like he's like i roll a 10 i'm like it
goes up 20 feet
dude
sam how high do you think you would have
let it go if he rolled a natural 20.
100.
because we well we established that
later now that i know well like there's
another moment where he throws something
100 feet on a 20.
he jumps on we know the distance of his
strength now
he he didn't jump on her feet he ended
up climbing but
yeah
this is insane
so sam when we get into a fight
in the game like when you're putting
like bad guys in front of us like
what would happen if we didn't do a good
job
like what like you know like when we're
fighting tough enemies and like if you
roll poorly or we just make a bad call
would you have just been like well you
guys died at the end and that would have
been the end of the the series like how
would that have worked well yeah there's
a little bit of that i mean the thing is
is that
um
like you know enemies like
how do i say it like i try not to get
too emotional like in those moments like
you can like i'm not trying to be like
hey i want to get them killed here it's
like
i just want to create like
you know a moment where it's like hey
let's let's play this out in a smart way
so to speak like like you know
rewarding smart decisions is like all i
think about
in those moments right but like yeah
yeah you could totally die and that'd be
the end of that
but it's it's partially just because
like it's tough to know
exactly like it took that whole this
whole campaign for me to really get a
good grip on like
what a fair fight for your party is
it's hard
because once you start introducing
uh magical weapons you throw the math
out
and the math drastically changes the
moment you pass level four
um it's it gets so complicated
yeah
uh it definitely does
trislet on the youtube chat this looks
like real miniatures
oh i think they're talking about the
scams
either that or the actual footage of the
real miniatures yeah yeah that would be
that would be the funniest
hey this looks like a d game
james glasses off you know he's serious
are you guys playing d and d
oh man i should have made a brandy
o'daniel costume that would have been
hilarious that should have been my that
should have been the name of my alter
ego maybe in next campaign
so this is sick with all the time and
effort that went to season one i mean
right on top of the premiere is maybe
the hard time to ask this question but
are you guys encouraged to do season two
or you're like oh man that seems so
daunting i i mean
i personally am encouraging myself and
you guys to do a season two
uh
uh yeah well it's on a technical level i
feel like yeah there are a few more
things we can do
and
i'm excited to do that and even
sam you could talk about the uh you
could talk about this if you want is sam
and i have been shooting ideas back and
forth on
where the story could potentially go to
just get sam's brain brewing
oh no we have it it's all written
well like the out the outline is there
and it's pretty sweet
and it's just as funny it's funnier and
more intense than the first one
it's kind of like it's boston dynamics 2
versus boston dynamics one yeah there
you go
if that's the best comparison i can make
right now
the best way to experience this podcast
episode is by putting this
next to the episode
and watching the episode on mute
i don't i think
i think a lot of people have never
witnessed dnd content before
this yeah i mean there's not a lot of
people like our crew content
well there's a very specific like blend
or mix of like d content online i most
content is like a podcast where it's
essentially right yeah it's it's video
live of the mind and not as slow
necessarily but it's
you know it's low edited yeah yeah it's
real-time
you know what's funny yeah how all the
cuts of like ren's like cringing face
and all his squirms as we were doing the
spider stuff
uh because i like in the moment i'm just
like yeah it's d d it's a cave you're
spiders like whatever like no big deal
so i'm like throwing down spider
managers all over the place
[Laughter]
only after watching the cuts and like
all the like close-ups that you guys
were cutting to and like punches of rain
going like
constantly threw up and i was like oh
yeah i forgot about like his
extreme
like aversion to spiders yeah and then
there's a moment
when you guys are walking through the
hall and then you start narrating what
the spiders are doing around them he
just like starts like
really having a moment because his
imagination zoom in on his face there we
there was a zoom in in one version as a
two shot most of the time i said yeah i
mean there's there's still plenty in
there of him there's plenty
i there was
an active digital zoom into his face and
i was like no i'm not going to do that
to ren i'd rather just keep it as a
locked off close-up or a locked off
two-shot
you should have done a slow push
dude
nico's face
is i think it's yeah it's in this
episode in the first episode near the
end
jake you start rolling uh to use the
rope and i punched into nico when he saw
your dice rolls yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so much is communicated from nico which
is like i feel so bad for jake
uh
i think everyone started at level five
is that correct
wait did this just jump back
did the youtube version just jump back
in time no no it's all no no
okay
spiders are the chipmunks of this insect
world
[Laughter]
dude i hope some rando
vegan
instagrammer
screencaps nico saying we shouldn't kill
animals that don't do any harm to us i
see that as murder
he goes nico's character is a vegan
druid
unless the animal attacks them first and
then niko's going to town
right unless that um someone was like
hey carmichael uh how do you decide uh
what's 75 of the footage to cut
um
when i lose interest in what i'm
watching
yeah
well like we had that discussion too
before we're like all right let's talk
about like
approaches here
and like the one thing i really was
fixating on was
you know very frequently you're supposed
to be talking about a story
in real time as it's happening but so
frequently because you're just at a
table you know you don't it's not like
there's a timer you have to make a
decision you know
um so people would say hey here's a
situation should we do this and then
should we do that oh maybe we could do
that maybe we do that and then it turns
out that whole conversation took place
within like six seconds of like a fight
scene while everyone was like mid-air
you know what i'm saying like it was
like totally out of context so so
there's a lot of like the hypothetical
conversations yeah
exactly and so like cutting all that out
is great because now when people aren't
like
it's not like something is exploding and
then there's a whole conversation as to
which way to duck it's like no something
blows up which way did you move and like
just keeping it a lot more direct
because that way it's i think a lot
easier for people to follow the story
since it's so much of it is in the
dialogue in the audio and just hearing
people explain what they're doing
that the moment you accidentally put in
something that doesn't happen if you if
you have a conversation about something
that doesn't happen
like
some people might distract not realize
that that didn't happen yeah um and
that's borderline one of the hard parts
about playing d d i would say like live
is
you
can't really do that as much
you know unless you establish the
setting of like
uh
we're hiding and we're going to make a
quick plan of action
yeah well because also like everyone
else has an opinion too so like you
still see a ton of it in this first
episode of like ren does something and
everyone's like no don't do that yeah
or like vice versa you know it's it's uh
yeah it's it can be like really really
confusing and jarring yeah but there's
also moments where you want to like
not do that
and you want to leave it in because
kind of the moment you want to hear
everyone's point of view and you want to
kind of hear the group think kind of
happen
somebody's like somebody's like i can
tell the pre-scripted stuff
oh yeah the writers on this show did a
great job yeah like
that on youtube yeah you know
nothing is pretty scripted no jake no
joke aside it's a massive thing when it
comes to the d d content out there
everyone
always thinks things are written
really yeah even critical role gets it
they're like
who's writing this
do you guys understand how many hours
the game is writing it
who did the sound design on this
the mixed live action and unreal stuff
looks so effing good
sam
it
sam did uh some sound effects i did
sound effects we both did the mixing
it's kind of a team effort
yep just constantly
redoing each other's waters work enough
times until it evens out
um the best thing about this show is
after is how much you want to watch the
next episode after you watch yeah i'm so
happy about that
like yeah
it's just
it it yeah it gets it just really starts
to
like dig in
the best compliment ever was before we
did any of the green screen or had any
of the vfx in there and it was just like
this is the rough edit for us to
approach vfx
uh jake goes i'm gonna watch like the
first five minutes and then he comes
back i watch the whole episode
yeah that's a good start yeah
oh man all right yeah next time we got a
so many messages
seven thousand people are watching live
on youtube yeah
wow next time we gotta get the actual 3d
models of these miniatures directly from
wizards of the coast
so we don't have to scan everything
90 of the minis are
like actually official like
so i'd like they and i know when you
when you see pre-release like images of
all the models they show you the 3d
models because you know they haven't
like cast them yet that's right
so i know they're out there
but that would save so much time
yeah that would save
weeks
yeah
do you think that they're rigged those
models
probably not nope oh definitely not
they're like sculpted okay
i do love the fact that we
uh sam and i both agreed early on to
like add sound effects uh to
some of the voices that sam does
just because it starts like having we
start having you know
a whole other party in the room
can you imagine if this was live
that'd be so hard
i know everyone would have to get
frickin pocket watches and green vests
and stuff and like top hats with
steampunk glasses no no everyone on the
green screen doing the actions they're
wearing mocap gear to mocap as the
players at the table oh like that kind
of live like oh jesus
yeah
it would be impossible
just playing d d live is hard
yeah oh we got another spammer let me
get rid of him
boom
see you buddy
all right let's go back to corridor
band
quest time
the horn
so
is the horn
hold on bad review it's good but it's
more just sam talking and what's up the
others i would really love to have seen
more banter from the rest of the cast 5
out of 10.
it's eight hours of us banting i love
that i love that you guys are getting
the same notes uh not same notes same
comments that essentially fables gets
the same that critical row gets
dimension 20 everyone
just complains at the beginning of it
and then everyone who sticks around to
like you know
episodes later they're like this is like
a great
dude i want low stakes
exposition you all arrive at a tavern
with no mission
[Laughter]
is there a place to sit no we should do
that we should do low stakes d and d
just for one
one episode no dude it's a side quest
one low stakes episode
these characters
like
it's like there's a minimum of
can we do four hours
sam can we do a side quest episode
on what happened uh with the orphans and
everyone just plays an orphan of the
orphan team
yeah like it's just it's just when
they're reverend mcallister's out
they're at the safe house like just
waiting for him to come back
[Laughter]
one whole game session is just us
playing orphans that's a backstory
that's important for the main story
and depending on your choices it changes
what happens in the main storyline
because of the flashback that you're
playing
yes yes this is a season episode it has
season related to d 1.5
[Laughter]
that's that's so intense in meta it's
like you guys are trying to figure out a
mystery and the only way you can figure
it out is to play as the characters that
had to do with the inciting event
i love it
whoa
it's so intense in meta
sammy did a good job with your voice
acting on this have you ever thought
about actually trying to do voice acting
yeah but he's got a company to run with
you guys yeah i guess he does do voice
acting arguably sammy is doing
professional voice acting
yeah it's it's fun but yeah
i just don't want to do auditions it's
you won't have to audition for the roles
that uh we go over
yeah for at coordinators you
automatically get the role here
i mean the best actors position it's
like an audition basically
yeah
there there's a bts episode that needs
to come out on crew cuts uh sam
auditioning for dm
or no it's the secret backstory that
i've just been putting together a really
good acting reel over the last 10 years
that's well it's like the whiskey reel
sam and i have a secret whiskey drinking
just the dead body reel and then there's
the whiskey drinking wheel
we still need to do that on your website
we got to do samborsky.com and it said
and it's
whisk my whiskey drinking my 2021
whiskey drinking reel and my 2021 dead
body reel
all the shots of you as a dead body in
all the different pieces you've been in
well the dead body one's easy because
it's just a bunch of shots of someone
laying in costume and you just try and
comp them into other movies
oh like the freeze frames and it zooms
in and like you raise your head and wink
[Laughter]
i know you probably think i'm dead right
now oh that's how it starts it scans
across like
an apocalyptic scene
and then it finds your body and it zooms
in on it and and you wake up a little
bit and you go
hey
i know you probably think that i'm dead
right now but this is just my dead body
real
i wonder if this will help get is it
scripted
i think so dude if you if you notice uh
in the footage while you guys are
watching the episode everyone has papers
in front of them they're reading their
lines in the script as we're going wait
did somebody say that for real
someone's asking if this is scripted i'm
just giving the explanation so they
understand how well written this is yeah
this is why it took a year is like we
had to write hours of
words
takes a lot
what does the horn do
was the [ __ ] never in like a a game
that was recorded yeah so where is this
from
wait no i'll tell you what the horns the
horns i want to hear the backstory of
the horn
okay so
butler the original i got it yeah ricky
ray butler was like hey you want to play
some d d with you guys and ricky is like
he runs some
i don't it's not even an mcn it's like
it's a huge you online like advertising
firm
um
and you know he's always been wanting to
play d so i was like all right so we all
got together nico and jake myself and
him and one of his buddies and it was
just like a simple like uh
you guys are poor and there's a town
with a bunch of rats in it they're gonna
pay you to kill the rats
it's like that kind of
level one campaign yeah
and you know just going through it i
think
like they're going in a place they found
like a treasure chest and i was like oh
shoot i don't have a plan for what's in
here so i like literally just file
through the pages super fast it becomes
the horn of blasting that they find in
there
and uh jeez yeah
that
yeah no it's it's like it's a it's a
canon dnd item okay
but yeah i thought you just made it up
no i didn't make it up this this one's
this one's like a legit like historical
d d artifact like leona's tiny hut
yes yeah
it was so much fun because of how wrong
everything went when they used it that
it's like the allure of great power with
comedic
backfiring potential
of a character that can permanently go
deaf
like after misusing it my character
doesn't go deaf i think after using it
yeah your character was permanently deaf
after you
that character's that character's still
alive though i should bring her back
bring her back brain curve
i know
i was campaigning
i was a rogue a female rogue
yeah you were a female but you forgot
that you write wrote female and you
didn't tell anyone that it was female
that's right yeah and so we all just
assumed you were a male rogue right
that's
and so the whole second half of that
campaign
was just dedicated to
jake committing to becoming a female
character with by getting a sex change
surgically yeah yeah and we went and we
went and tried to find a doctor things
went horribly sideways
yeah
i was knocked out for a while
but then after that i decided that i
wanted to remain my birth gender after
yeah it all went wrong yeah
but yeah yeah
that was a close one close call that was
a great campaign we got a comment
violence
i am really happy with how the rope gig
turned out yeah straight up adam west
batman yeah i was like the moment you
guys were saying that
and we were go and
sing that at the table i was like how do
we do this for real
it's like how do we because my brain
instantly goes to not vfx how do i do
this practically
and i was like wait there has to be a
rope gig of some kind
and
then my brain started thinking because
one of the ideas was to capture on green
screen i was like oh we could do it
sideways
that'd be amazing should we have five do
we have five or six
uh at the table
yeah uh one two three
four
five six
seven and then yeah we it's we started
with six and we went to seven we went to
seven i would like
if we were to do another season i would
like to uh add
two more and we record with nine cameras
as long as we do it in 1080
yeah let's there's really no reason to
do this in 4k
no i i shot in 4k so we could do
punch-ins and get singles
yeah did that work yeah it happens all
the time
yeah every time you see a single of
someone like that static it's a punch in
yeah yeah okay so so okay so we want to
shoot in 4k but then
yeah i i edited
did you export in 1080 or 4k i edit it
in 1080
and then export it in 4k so people can
have the grass uh gratifying moment of
going to 4k on
their monitors
it looks so good on the site like i know
we're we're streaming it right now but
once the actual episode publishes
um in 25 minutes it like it's so
crisp on the site
and that's just 1080 i'm just on a 1080
monitor i'm i'm so happy that it looks
good
we're at the part where wren has fallen
to his death without his death it's
almost dead he's half death
his half death
you're almost half dead
well bob went with splat
well bob's going to need a chiropractor
so now it's now it's picking up see this
is the challenging part with dnd it's
like not like a movie you can just
script like a cool little you know
actually opening and then a hook then a
mystery like it needs to build yeah
yeah it's like all right here we go the
game's starting rolling
let's literally do that on the next
campaign
and it goes okay welcome to season two
roll initiative and we don't introduce
the characters until after the combat
we just literally yeah you immediately
start fighting and you don't even know
who your enemy is at first
one question per turn
yeah
oh my god let's seriously start it with
initiative though that's super i
remember sam you remember uh
when we were
starting those we were building the
table and you were talking about the
first episode actually
being a
a dream sequence
oh jeez yeah
the whole campaign was totally different
last time where it starts with everyone
being like trapped in a psychic dream
sequence that they have to realize they
have to escape
but it got way too complicated and
wait it put all the exposition way too
late in the campaign for it to work
and it ca and it kind of made everyone's
choices in the first episode arguably
pointless
yeah exactly and it it kind of just like
removes a little bit of the fun of the
game
use the horn
[Laughter]
deaf in his character multiple times
because that's the thing it's like it's
one out of five that you go deaf
that's a permanently death permanently
deaf
you know how
difficult that would make things so yeah
it was permanently deaf in your party
it's like well you can talk to him but
you don't you've nev you haven't learned
a sign language to communicate yet yeah
he's also the lowest intelligence of the
group yeah he doesn't know another
language guys
you'd have to go visit some like magi to
like teach you a language that you could
communicate with that person
there's so much there's so many funny
things like that that like seem like
kind of small and inconsequential but
like uh then there's another one that's
a hilarious rule with ghosts in the game
where if a ghost like physically passes
through you
in in d like the rules state that
basically you have to roll a check
against this ghost and if you fail
you age like five to ten years yeah so
you can age up to like 50 years
for just just in an instant just from a
ghost passing through you
yeah okay because i remember we were
playing a game with jan where that
happened to him and he got he aged 40
years
still alive he just got super old
like
yeah he was a human character he was
still alive because he was a younger
character
but uh
it's just like hilarious to think like
oh now you're like literally a geezer
now
for the rest of this game
sam uh we got a got a compliment on the
youtube one a great dm calls out their
mistakes and keeps the show going on
superb work
yeah it happens
your marketing is really not humble
i mean it's true whatever come on
uh people watching live on youtube 7.9
technically let's wait for that eight
until we hit it uh i'm sorry i do
roundup math
earlier
that's how i get my that's how i get my
budget right
you do that tax math
skill checks 20s are not automatic well
house rules for us
yeah that's a that's a 5e thing
most people ignore that yeah
but that's the thing is
they're going to be so many rule lawyers
in the comments
like it's so exhausting whatever
whatever
it's like if that's what you feel like
spending your time cheating
like it's art it's not like it affects
you
yeah it's like i i hate their dnd show
because they win all the time
honestly first page of
players handbook first page of dungeon
master guide
everything is filtered through the dm
the dm makes the final call
does it doesn't matter what the book
says
i think automatic fail or automatic
success on 20 to one is like perfect
i think that's a great great way to play
it
no matter how
like crazy the odds are like it's just
it's great
because sometimes you want that like
just oh that that works that's crazy
yeah yeah i think that also it also like
it works as an as a balance against
characters that have incredibly high uh
like values in certain areas you know
where about like no matter what they do
they're going to be above a 10 pretty
much on every single role right yeah
well it also gets the dm because like
sometimes i'm trying to make people lose
or try you know something like that like
i there is a little bit of that
happening here and there where it's like
it's like this is supposed to be hard or
i hear or even like here's a story point
that i really don't want to have screwed
up and someone rolls a 20 and it's like
all right it's like it's like concrete
proof that no matter what a player can
influence
this story
yeah
no matter what no matter how hard i want
something to go one way or another
it it keeps that power there
yeah the
i think the the reasoning for them to
remove
crits
and natural fails in skill checks was
like
oh you can't just nat uh roll in that 20
and move a mountain i was like it's like
yeah that let the dm decide that
oh we got our first net 20 of the game
yeah it was a truck the rope 100 feet up
into the air
critical hand
boy
will bob do the rest how hard you know
how hard it would be to throw a crumpled
up chunk of rope 100 feet but it's not
just a crumpled up rope it's 250 feet of
rope
it's funny how the comments have evolved
from like beginning people like ah
they're kind of like it's a little
stilted they're kind of quiet not super
energetic it's not a lot happening and
now it's just like people are dying and
shooting and i was like whoa
yeah bob is awesome he's gonna die
screw the skeleton guy i mean that's dnd
that's storytelling yeah i mean that's
the hardest challenge i think with
episode one here is like it's beginning
yeah yeah like it is kind of nice that
we have like such an extreme moment of
like a character falling off a 100-foot
cliff into a so great worm pit
is like a like the first thing that
happens
oh dude this this comment i'm gonna call
it now chippy is it is secretly a demon
that has infiltrated the crew he is the
final boss
[Laughter]
that would be so funny
and then we all decide to just kill the
skeletons anyway
[Laughter]
no like seriously like when dee is like
wait a second we should throw him in the
pit
dude
in the first in the first few episodes
he was so murder adverse
no but no he wasn't no he wasn't no like
this whole first episode he's like my
first action is to be prepared to shoot
anyone in the head
yeah dude throwing him in the pit
that's so worth filming that in live
action
it's so funny
people are pointing out that my no
killing
rules are fastly going away
i mean no it's not a killer it's okay
no it's but that's what that's called a
character arc
yeah i don't want to hurt anything
must destroy
i mean it didn't happen as extreme as it
did in the call the wild campaign where
she's like all right so we're going to
solve this by killing everyone yeah well
that was the point of that one i was
like literally was like i want these
characters to effectively be bad guys
like yeah
i want it's like here's barbarians and
their mission is to murder everyone
and make it like feel good make it make
it like a feel-good murder story
[Laughter]
the alaskan bull worm i need to go back
and watch that again i also need to
watch the cry fear series again
oh cry fear is great cry fear is like
some of the best
some of the best node
yeah glad to see some people are getting
20 just climbing up that wall
you see people getting introduced to
dungeons and dragons is uh makes me
happy also yeah i'd be like well this
looks cool how do you play this and it's
like yes yeah yes welcome which is the
coast at a recent poll on twitter unlike
how did you
get into dnd
uh did you
get invited to a game did you start a
game
uh
did you look it up or did you just watch
some actual play they had like 10 000
plus people who voted
and 90 was watching actual play content
that's crazy really
just just that's how they got introduced
to it watching somebody yeah
wow
just by watching other people play and
go that looks like fun i want that
wow
all right man this this campaign's
moving now people are like people are
just into it this is great this makes me
really 1 000. 8.1 000 viewers
six percent left on my ipad
8 200.
that's what i'm reading holy hell well
bob is insane
[Music]
oh this moment
it makes me really happy to see the
comments now discussing the actual
character moments and stories that's
like yes they're so satisfying to get to
those comments yep
uh i live for it um
i know i'm like we're talking son of a
dungeon but
on fables like once a day a comment
comes through talking about their
favorite character in a moment and it's
so nice
to just see that the story you're
creating with friends
people are taking in and enjoying it
yep
this guy the hebo and then the slow-mo
on d's face
he goes
he goes i don't know why but for some
reason it's difficult to watch this and
also discuss discuss network subnets in
a meeting
clearly i need to dump more points into
constitution and intelligence
[Laughter]
do d's phase in the slo-mo
yeah
he's watching this in the middle of a
work meeting
yeah that's great
it's all coming together guys
coming together
is this your card
i'm so glad we put this episode two
stuff oh yeah the website's on the rope
pull right now right yeah yeah yeah
youtube's just behind it they just
started uh
talking about setting up the rope yes
yeah yeah i'm glad we decided to drop
episode two on the same day too yeah
yeah it's such a good episode
yeah the second one is great
yeah the
the the marrying of the two
so like
recording wise we ended
the first episode
um
when we bob gets back to the top of the
cliff
and recording that's where we ended it
but an extra couple minutes
right yeah we went like maybe 10 more
minutes into episode two
to the moment where uh
yargo walks through the door
yeah and that's the hook
because now there's a sense of like oh
no what's going to happen great let's
cut
yeah
yeah oh on the website we're at the
point where i'm almost falling off the
rope
don't do it
i i'm so glad it was it was it was 11 so
i almost failed but yeah if i would have
failed that third time than i would have
been at the bottom of that pit dude that
worm would have eaten me
that would have been a great finale to
help me go down there and reanimate me
and then i would have come out as one of
those undead guys
that'd be pretty funny it would have
been a real situation this this rope
thing that we're talking about here with
the trying to go go across it that was
like a really good example of um
like me setting up a problem and
providing like no ideas for like really
how to solve it and just hoping that you
guys would kind of
try some stuff like i was like oh yeah
i'll have like a rope pulley mechanism
you can put a rope to but then like just
be like
yeah it's like there's not really any
other way to do it
like
i don't know
definitely could have ended up with
someone actually dying in the first
episode
well i could have used i could have used
my tiny hut down there if i would have
gotten in trouble but
you could use your tiny head down there
yeah next step would be something sort
of deep fake turn no you didn't have it
yeah
spoiler alert
well hey if it ain't lehman's
it ain't a hut it's not a hut
poor warren's delicate guitar fingers
do you know i'm on this youtube right
now watching it yeah
i love the rope
every time when someone communicates
something bad to
uh sam i make sure that it's a cut of
sam like expressing frustration or
sentence
yeah spoiler d dies in episode one
just because ren fell
like it makes this whole scene so much
better now too because you're like oh
it's down there
right away one of the people fell 100
feet like and he has the most health
points of anyone but anyone else who
died like balls is like no there's like
we've already established there's like a
worm down there right now
rope song luck
critical grab
song jake is a true bard jake is a true
bard
i was so happy on day one when jake
walked up to the table and put his
guitar there
i was like yes
i don't i don't care if the music bleeds
into other people's mics this is amazing
yeah i didn't i didn't realize that uh i
was actually my like like
i emulate a bard character a lot in life
and uh
because i didn't really know what they
were when i first started playing i was
like i'm a rogue i'm a fighter right you
know
and then i realized oh i'm actually not
good at i tried to play a wizard once
that did not go well it's hard
i'm playing a wizard in a gothic horror
campaign right now
and all i'm doing is just being afraid
of everything
well you especially when you're a
low-level wizard i yeah i'm level 3 18
hp
i have incredible wisdom
okay how's that going to help us kill
these rats
you know
this rope smells like [ __ ]
i guess i guess we missed that one
it's so good on the website
oh man
the credits on the website is there a
post scene after credits no not an
episode not episode one
five minutes uh dreamweaver
stolen
that's how's these credits going now
we'll get that
yeah next time we'll we can just add
everyone gets like two bonus credits of
their choice
yes
bonus credits
dreamweaver dreamweaver
lord of thought
of thought
scrolling master
dice inertia
nice
dice lord
yeah i love the bathroom shots they look
so good
the credits are super classy yeah they
are it's really nice they turned out
8.2 000 viewers on youtube
i think
we got a on the through the corridor
account
on the live chat
start mentioning that you guys can
continue watching episode two on the
website oh i've been hit i've been
saying that okay
dude the bathroom scene
dude the mentioned door scene
[Laughter]
we need puff in here
dude it'd be cool to have puffins
eight point three thousand
all right episode two is about to pop
off
i'm really glad people liked
this
yeah me too yeah me too
we put so much into it that uh you know
jake charming well done
overwhelmingly positive feedback my
phone literally just put a limit on my
youtube watch
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna switch over to the
actually i'll leave it on chat but in a
minute i'll switch over to the home page
and we'll get a little glimpse into
episode two people will go wait
is this just episode one again
fair
look at all those producer points
slangin
oh man the
challenge like i'm trying to like talk
on this podcast and read the chat at the
same time but like the words go so fast
i know i'm writing an email
oh come on somebody goes oh come on
classic
carmichael drop
leave them hanging
dude that's what you get is a big hook
you and i are now in a band
[Laughter]
man sick well this is pretty sweet can't
wait to release more of this episode two
live on
oh man
man so many people are like just
commenting right now i'm so happy that
youtube keeps the cr uh corridor crew
comment like hanging at the top as this
girl goes
yeah
yep
it's business time we got to send this
the links out to everyone
go get out of that
yo go get out of the balloon
literally
they'll make you go higher
drop them sandbags
all right sam's robotic he's robotic
sam's a robot
sam hey big congrats to you and big
congrats to you carmichael on this big
day seriously guys uh seriously you guys
deserve it you guys put out a ton of
work and you made something that
actually triggers real emotions which is
crazy triggered you are manipulating
people with your images and sounds and
words
it only took eight years but i didn't
here we go scott where are the episodes
all right guys i'm gonna sign off here
let me check everyone
all right thanks for listening congrats
man thanks for watching
jake and christian or just jam uh i'm
gonna tell you guys in a second here to
follow up with who and who you have not
sent emails to yet with the links dude
the bathroom band
all right
till next time
okay all right okay sam
so good
geez louise i'm gonna wait until episode
two drops do you guys want to sign off
on this live thing though
yeah probably
you mean for the podcast yep okay i mean
i feel like this is the the quiet
quietest podcast anyone's ever listened
to
well if this was the quietest podcast
you've ever listened to it's because it
was the loudest in our hearts and uh
you know
thanks for uh listening
uh i hope you check out at least the
first episode of son of a dungeon yes
please it's free on both
quarterdigital.com
and on youtube on court or crew
um and of course
i mean do i even need to push you to
watch episode two or
let the content do it yeah i'm not even
gonna say let's put let's put 12 hours
12 months of work to do the pushing for
us i'm not even going to sell you on
anything on this podcast
well
there was already there was already a
storyblocks integration earlier but hey
uh you know that was that was part of
another contract i have no control over
that
they just they just tell me where to
stand
and what to say
um all right so anyways
thank you everybody and uh
we'll see you later carmichael congrats
man
yeah thank you guys congrats thank you
for the opportunity of uh coming back
with a big blast
you bet yeah
you bet can i get more cameras now
we'll talk about it